Well, we are going to be flushing out
more truth, um especially around the
topic of the millennium.
There's a lot of confusion around it,
and as is my motto on Candid Truth, the
truth is not just an option, but is a
standard.
So, let's go ahead and take a look at
this because
like I said, lots of confusion.
And it's been repackaged so many
different ways in different
denominations, different churches,
different movements. And the New Age,
it's usually referred to as the Golden
Age. In other teachings, it's earthly
utopia.
There's political kingdom of God.
There's
church traditions planning
um
that Christ's return is going to be on
this fallen world before it is cleansed.
So, we really need to know, otherwise we
can fall for deception here.
All right. So, the first question we
have to ask ourself is
what are we going to base this off of?
And of course, we're going to base this
off of the Bible alone. So, no
traditions layered on top of it and
build each of these sequence of events
one step at a time. First of all,
some people might be asking themselves
also, what is the millennium? Most
systems will tell you that Christ reigns
on Earth for a thousand years with
people
still alive here.
But scripture paints a different
picture, and we're going to get into
that now.
Because
what happens at Christ's coming needs to
be
unraveled here to understand.
The righteous are raised
or transformed,
but all of them are taken up,
not left on Earth.
To prove this, we need to go ahead and
look at the Bible verse 1 Thessalonians
4:16
through 17. It says, "For the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout, with the voice of the archangel,
and with the trump of God, and the dead
in Christ shall rise first.
Then we which are alive and remain shall
be caught up together with them in the
clouds
to meet the Lord in the air. And so
shall we ever be with the Lord."
All right. So, as we see, this is the
righteous.
This is a very important point.
But, when we say the righteous are going
to be the ones being caught up in the
air to meet the Lord, we also need to
clarify that Christ is in the clouds
waiting for them. Let's clarify also the
real Christ Jesus doesn't set foot on
this Earth or on the ground not at a
second coming. The Bible tells us there
they're going to say when they say
Christ has come, "See him in the desert
or see him where he is speaking here and
there."
Do not go because it isn't Jesus. It's
not the real Jesus. So, that's the point
I'm making. The real Jesus, according to
the verse here,
is in the clouds, and we get caught up
to meet him, and he does not even touch
the Earth. But, we have to also clarify
something
something I'm seeing a lot today as
well. In politics, there's a huge
movement going on where they believe
that they can bring on a kingdom, an
earthly kingdom that is of God, but no
earthly kingdom is set up here during
this moment in time.
Let me clarify. It is arrogant for any
human beings to think that they can go
ahead
and make anything perfect
with them being as imperfect as every
human being
is. We cannot make something perfect if
we are not perfect, and we are
definitely fallible, imperfect beings.
But, let alone to think that we can make
a perfect world
when only God can do that.
So, claiming that we are going to become
a Christian nation again, return to God,
this
phrase implies force being used against
our will to do it,
which is an ungodly act in the first
place, which belongs to the devil and is
a signature pattern of things
revolving around coercion and force that
is
always wrong.
There is no biblical command, by the
way,
or divine calling,
or ability of any human being
to build a godly kingdom
on Earth so we can hand it back to God
when he comes at his second coming.
Jesus answered when he came the first
time, "My kingdom is not of this world.
If my kingdom were of this world, then
would my servants fight that I should
not be delivered to the Jews, but now is
my kingdom not from hence."
So, when this political movement happens
and people say this, it isn't true.
But, when we bounce back
to understanding that the righteous go
up and are taken,
whether they are raised from the grave
or they are still living when Jesus
comes back, all of them go in the air to
meet him. But, what about the wicked?
Here's where we clarify. The wicked are
destroyed at his coming. 2 Thessalonians
2:8.
"And then shall that wicked be revealed,
whom the Lord shall consume with the
spirit of his mouth, and shall destroy
with the brightness of his coming." So,
the wicked will be destroyed completely
by the brightness of brightness of his
coming.
The wicked become the slain of the Lord,
it says. "And the slain of the Lord
shall be at that day from one end of the
Earth even unto the other end of the
Earth. They shall not be lamented,
neither gathered nor buried. They shall
be dung upon the ground." All wicked
that were still alive when he comes, and
again, that have always been dead, they
will all be stricken down and be in the
grave and held there.
So, that clarifies the righteous and the
wicked, what happens to them at the
second coming.
The next question we have
is what happens to the Earth? In
Jeremiah 4:23
through 28,
"I beheld the Earth, and lo, it was
without form and void. And the heavens,
and they had no light.
I beheld the mountains, and lo, they
trembled, and all the hills moved
lightly.
I beheld, and lo, there was no man, and
all the birds of the heavens were fled.
I beheld, and lo, the fruitful place was
a wilderness, and all the cities thereof
were broken down at the presence of the
Lord and by his fierce anger." So, as we
said, it'll be a desolate place.
Basically, that's what I'm getting at.
I'm already summing it up, but there's
no there's no man, there are no more
birds, there is no more fruitful places,
it's a wilderness, there are no cities,
all because the Lord came in his fierce
anger, finally he just slew everything.
And then, as we continue right there at
the where it says, "For thus hath the
Lord said, the whole land," here we go,
"shall be desolate. Yet will I not make
a full end.
For this shall the Earth mourn, and the
heavens above be black, because I have
spoken it. I have purposed it. I will
not repent, neither will I turn back
from it." Just to clarify, just in case
someone is not
fully understanding this, it is not a
localized event that is happening here.
It is all of the Earth.
And
all the cities.
The whole Earth is a desolation.
Everything is at an end.
And there are no buildings left standing
at the presence of God. That is so
important because of those who believe
in the
Satan's little season. Many of these
details are important that we are
covering just currently because
no buildings will be left standing, no
people,
all of these things.
So, we cannot be in that little season.
This is the verse I need also to that
point of the little season.
People think that civilizations, again,
buildings, having children,
uh marrying, procreating, all these
things can happen
after Christ comes, but as it says here,
"For in the resurrection, they neither
marry nor are given in marriage." Why
would God choose those words, those very
words, "In the resurrection, they
neither marry"? He's being very specific
about when.
"Nor are they given in marriage, but are
as the angels of God in heaven."
So, there will not be people being born
in the new Earth.
Who or what's happening to Satan?
Basically, let's talk about that.
And it says, "And I saw an angel come
down from heaven,
having the key of the bottomless pit,
and a great chain in his hand. And he
laid hold on the dragon, that old
serpent, which is the devil and Satan,
and bound him a thousand years, and cast
him into the bottomless pit, and shut
him up, and set a seal upon him, that he
should deceive the nations no more,
till a thousand years should be
fulfilled. And after that, he must be
loosed a little season.
It said the bottomless pit, and the very
word we see
in the concordance here in Greek is
abyss.
Abyssos, okay?
And
that's in Revelation 20:1.
And as we cross-reference it, we see
that legion begged to go into the pigs.
Remember that story? So, they wouldn't
be in the abyss as well. Or the spirit
realm, sorry, without a physical host.
Satan does not dwell inside the earth,
but rather on this earth wreaking havoc.
We know that, but
just to read it to you guys, Luke 8:23,
and they besought him. This is the King
James Bible version.
And they besought him that he would not
command them to go out into the deep.
Okay, that's one translation.
New King James version is and they be
they begged him that he would not
command them to go into the abyss.
All right. International Standard
Version, then the demons
began begging Jesus not to order them to
go into the bottomless pit.
That very verse that we just read in
three different translations is Luke
8:31. In Greek, it is also abyssos or
abyss.
They don't want to be sent into a realm
where they don't have a physical host,
where it is with
with kind of without
any substance.
The devil and Satan, who deceives the
world, the whole world, he was cast to
the earth, and his angels were cast out
with him. There we go. That's
the proof for that, that he is indeed
on this earth with us, not in the earth.
I will make that point as well,
as some might think, but that he was
cast to this earth. And without any
host, they were begging to go into the
pigs at least have something to possess,
and this was also called the bottomless
pit or abyss.
And it was also used in Revelation, as
we saw, as well, the same word for the
desolate earth, when Satan has no living
beings to possess or
interfere with, and he is completely
beside himself
during the millennium.
What we mentioned before is that an
angel with chains is binding Satan to
the earth, while the wicked are dead in
the ground, all of them.
The earth is empty and ruined, and he is
effectively
imprisoned
on a dead planet.
And the righteous are up
in heaven with Christ.
And this is Revelation 20:4 to follow
that up to show this. It says, "And I
saw thrones, and they
they sat upon them,
and judgment was given unto them. And I
saw the souls of them that were beheaded
for the witness of Jesus, and for the
word of God, and which had not
worshipped the beast." So, the
righteous, again,
"neither his image,
neither had received his mark upon their
foreheads or in their hands. And they
lived and reigned with Christ a thousand
years."
Jesus already told us, by the way, as we
go further, he said, "In my Father's
house are many mansions. If it were not
so, I would have told you. I go to
prepare a place for you. And if I go and
prepare a place for you, I will come
again and receive you unto myself."
That's kind of the being caught up in
the air. Like, he will not even
come down for you. He will have you
be caught up to him.
Very interesting language to be received
unto myself.
"That where I am,
there you may be also."
Okay?
Just an interesting point there.
He doesn't say,
"I come and I will set
up here on earth with you."
He says, "I will take you where I am,
and that is in the heavens."
Okay? And by the way, where is Christ
right now? We should know this. We need
to clarify this.
It says
in Hebrews
8:1,
"Now the things which we have spoken,
this is the sum.
We have such a high priest who is set on
the right hand of the throne of the
majesty
in the heavens." So, he is in the
heavens right now, as well.
Sequence is that Christ returns.
He raises all the righteous to go up in
the clouds to meet him. He doesn't even
step one toenail onto this earth before
it is cleansed.
The righteous reign with him
in heaven during this time.
Now we come to the question, "Well, if
they go to heaven with him, the
righteous go and they are with him in
heaven,
what are they doing?"
You know, are they just kind of
lounging,
wasting time, playing their harp, as
some people believe?
Well,
we are
not going to be doing those things and
not building cities, but we are going to
be
if we are the righteous, we are going to
be judging.
"Do they not know that the saints, okay,
saints are the righteous, shall judge
the world? And if the world shall be
judged by you,
are you unworthy to judge the smallest
matters?
Know ye not that we shall judge angels?
How much more things that pertain to
this life?"
Okay? So, again and again, we the
righteous will be the judge
judging in heaven during this
millennium.
And we have to think of this whole time
as a heavenly review period,
where God,
according to Daniel 7 and 10, will open
the books.
The redeemed understand what they are
called to do, to judge from those books.
Daniel 7:10, "A fiery stream issued and
came forth
from before him.
Thousand thousands ministered unto him,
and 10,000 times 10,000 stood before
him. The judgment was set, and the books
were opened."
What about the wicked
during
the thousand years?
"But the rest of the dead lived not
again until the thousand years were
finished."
Revelation 20:5.
So, there are no second chances.
There's no earthly coexistence
or commingling
of
evil
and righteous anymore.
There's no more building, no more
cities, no more marriages, no more
children.
No more fruitfulness, it even seems.
It's just a barren wasteland of
wilderness.
All right. So, what happens after
the thousand years?
This is where everything returns to
earth.
Number one, the New Jerusalem comes
down.
The wicked are then raised,
and Satan is loosed
from those chains,
and
he takes the wicked that are now raised,
and he
deceives them
into thinking that they can now come up
against God's
New Jerusalem. Revelation 20:7, 8, and
9. And it says, "When the thousand years
are expired,
Satan shall be loosed out of his prison,
and shall go out to deceive the nations
which are in the four quarters of the
earth, Gog and Magog, to gather them
together to battle."
They're so deceived
um in their sin still, that Satan has
sway over them to think that they can
even battle against God.
Anyway,
the number of whom,
and this is to clarify, this is the
wicked that are raised now,
"The number of whom is as the sand of
the sea."
When God says, "Straight and narrow is
the path, and few will find it," he
really means it.
So, the majority and all the other
people on the the broad path
to destruction,
that's what he's talking about. That's
the number of the sand of the sea, which
the wicked will equate to, because very
few will actually find
be righteous and find their way to
heaven.
"And ye shall tread down the wicked, for
they shall be ashes under the soles of
your feet in the day that I shall do
this, saith the Lord of hosts." Again,
that is
the wicked. They will burn.
So, it is
that they aren't burning forever, but
that they are
going to be ashes under the New
Jerusalem and under the feet of the
righteous. Now, I want to clarify
something even deeper that actually
confuses a lot of people. It's kind of
the one of the other main deceptions
here. It says many people wonder why
Satan must be released after a thousand
years of peace on Earth with Jesus as
king. Will Satan deceive believers who
have lived with Jesus for a thousand
years on Earth?
Some say it will be their offspring who
will be deceived. So, we already talked
about this a little bit. How could Satan
deceive
people
after the judgment books are opened,
after the the verdict has been given,
and there's peace on Earth with Jesus as
king? Well, he's not going to be
deceiving believers. He's going to be
deceiving the wicked
that he takes and he makes them
self-deceived
that they can come up against the Lord
and his people
when the New Jerusalem comes down.
Once again, we're going to emphasize for
in the resurrection they neither marry
nor are given in marriage, but are as
the angels of God in heaven. So, there
will not be people being born in the new
Earth to be deceived.
To be deceived. No, that's not going to
happen.
Okay?
And they went up on the breadth of the
Earth, it says in the Bible, and
compassed the camp of the saints about
and the beloved city. And fire came down
from God out of heaven and devoured
them. So, this is the deceived wicked
who come up with Satan, who come up
against the city or camp of the saints
as it's saying.
And fire came down from God out of
heaven and just devours them. I just
read this one of being ashes under the
soles of the righteous feet. And
as we read Revelation 20
1 through verse 9 now.
Then, those are all the things that have
to happen in sequence in in that exact
order and way
before we get to Revelation 21:1 and it
says, "And I saw a new heaven and a new
Earth.
For the first heaven and the first Earth
were passed away, and there was no more
sea."
So, finally, here we go. The Earth is
finally restored.
This is when God dwells with man on
Earth.
Meaning, the Earth has been cleansed.
And
the New Jerusalem came down.
Everyone's been sealed. Their fate has
been sealed. The wicked have been
completely
annihilated. And
we
get to be with Christ
in a perfect world.
The perfect Earth isn't during the
thousand years,
but rather after the thousand years is
finished. That's a defining
clarification as well of
a point that's needing to be understood.
So, listen.
There are several deceptions I have
pointed out in this.
That Jesus will not touch his feet to
the Earth at all.
People don't know that.
They don't know that
Satan's little season cannot be true and
is not the truth.
They don't know that the millennium is
not on Earth, but it is in heaven.
That nations continuing as usual, again
with this little um
season idea is not true. It can't go on
there. There will not be any nations,
buildings, anything going on or humans
for that matter on Earth
when Christ comes back.
And Christ will not rule over sinners
that are still alive.
When we think about those things
actually being understood in that
twisted way, we have to understand that
it's a counterfeit that Satan's trying
to prepare us for to be gullible enough
to be deceived by.
That way, when the Antichrist comes and
he is walking about on Earth,
ah
he has just prepared you with the the
deception of the millennium being on
Earth to receive him when he comes as
Christ. And his message is
and we'll think that it is him if you
don't know that the real Christ won't
touch the ground.
The millennium will not be on Earth.
And no giving and taking, no kids, no
descendants can even be had because
Remember, actually this is really good
point also. Remember that in the
twinkling of an eye
our bodies are changed at the second
coming of Christ also.
And when we get our new bodies, hate to
say this, but it says we are again made
like the angels. And angels do not
procreate.
Do not give in marriage once again.
So, no descendants, no children will be
had.
If people believe that somehow we are in
the little season and yet there are
sinners still and
righteous, perhaps people who think
they're righteous living amongst each
other,
and there's children being had and
there's
supposedly, I don't know, other things
going on and buildings that are still
going up and things, we are definitely
not
at the second coming or it has not
happened yet.
The harvest has not been gathered yet,
in other words.
So, all of these deceptions, I hope it
has been clear. I hope I've covered them
all.
But any of these type of deceptions
without understanding it will keep you
focused on the earthly kingdoms
happening.
It'll also prepare people to accept,
like I said, the false Christ ruling on
Earth.
The real Christ won't do that.
But it'll make people think that that is
true and what will happen.
And also believe blurs
the lines between the fallen world and
the restored one somehow happening at
the same time.
And that's not true. It can't happen.
Again, do not
light and dark cannot coexist with each
other.
It will, I mean, the righteous and sin
sinful people on Earth right now are
having to grow together like the wheat
and the tares. Yes, I get that. We are
during that time here, but when second
coming actually happens,
the wheat and the tares are separated as
we see. One goes with Christ cuz he
harvested us, cuz they were righteous,
or the other one will stay where they
are, slain by him in the ground,
put to rest before they
await their judgment, their
annihilation.
All right. So, I
have been over this
um several times,
but don't get tripped up on this.
Only go with what scripture says.
For some reason,
a lot of people have got tripped up on
this because they're listening only to
what preachers are preaching from the
pulpits.
It's something that sounds good to the
ear and feels good.
Sounds better,
perhaps,
but it is not written in God's word.
So, be careful.
The Bible and the Bible alone. Go read
that Bible. Look at the verses I have
given.
Because
you do not want to be deceived.
So, I hope this is a blessing.
Um we love you guys. We want it to be
clear. We want to see you guys in
heaven. And so,
I just pray this blesses and
makes
many people understand what is to
happen.
What the true events of the millennium
and the circumstances surrounding it
are.